Guten Tag mein Name ist Enes Cüncü und ich bin der Diensthabende Arzt. Wie heißen Sie den?
Ich heiß Frank Zimmermann. Können Sie Ihr Vor- und Nachname bitte langsam bestabieren?
Ja der Vorname ist Frank, F, R, A, N, K und Zimmermann ist der Familienname Z, I, M, E, R, M, A, N.
Doppel N. Okay, danke schön. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 67 Jahre.
Und wann gebaut wurden Sie geboren? Am 2. Mai 58.
Wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1,73.
Kennen Sie Ihr aktuelles Gewicht? Ich wiege so 78, 79 Kilo.
Danke für all diese Informationen. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe solche heftigen Bauchschmerzen. Vor allen Dingen auf der linken Seite tut es weh.
Die sind so langsam aufgetreten und sind immer stärker geworden.
Am Anfang habe ich gedacht, naja gut Bauchschmerzen hat man ja mal.
Aber jetzt wird es wirklich immer mehr und das ist so unten im Bauch.
Also ganz schlimm ist es, wenn ich, also direkt nach dem Essen ist es unangenehm.
Ich habe neulich mal so ein ziemlich fettiges Essen gegessen und da hat es richtig weh getan.
Und ja, also am besten geht es eigentlich, wenn ich sitze, dann tut es nicht so doll weh.
Aber sonst ist es auch so, dass ich nicht so gut stehen kann und auch beim Rumlaufen, dann merke ich, dass das weh tut.
Okay, ich verstehe. Sie haben gesagt linken Bauchschmerzen.
Ja im linken und unten.
Linken und unten oder?
Ja links unten genau.
Okay danke. Und Sie haben gesagt, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, so ganz langsam hat das angefangen vor zwei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen.
Na ja gut, dann hatte ich auch mal ein bisschen Blehungen und dann hatte ich zwischendurch auch mal ein bisschen Durchfall.
Ja, also dann denkt man ja immer, wenn die Verdauung nicht so gut klappt, dann hatten wir Bauchschmerzen.
Aber als es dann jetzt gar nicht besser wurde, habe ich gedacht, jetzt muss ich doch mal zum Arzt gehen.
Ja und jetzt sind die Schmerzen auch wirklich, also ganz schön doll geworden.
Ja, dass es eine gute Entscheidung zu hier gekommen ist und wir werden Ihnen helfen.
Ganz gut, ja.
Ja und hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden schon einmal?
Ja, also wie gesagt, dass ich so ein bisschen Bauchbeschwerden habe, das kenne ich eigentlich schon.
Das habe ich eigentlich schon seit zwei Jahren, kann ich sagen, ist mir das aufgefallen,
dass ich immer mal Phasen habe, wo ich ganz verstopft bin und wo ich das Gefühl habe,
also war ich kein Tagelang nicht so richtig auf die Toilette und dann habe ich wieder Tage,
wo ich mehrmals gehen muss und wo ich auch so ein bisschen Weichenstuhl habe.
Also der Bauch, der macht mir schon eigentlich längere Zeit ein bisschen Ärger.
Okay, können Sie diese Beschwerden beschreiben?
Zum Beispiel Drucken, Stechen?
Also Druck ist es auf alle Fälle.
Und noch?
Na, Drucken, okay.
Drückend, ich würde nichts anderes, also Stechen oder so, Stechen tut es nicht.
Nee, es ist eigentlich sehr heftiger Druck, ja.
Okay, danke.
Und wo würden Sie diese Beschwerden auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10 einordnen?
Zum Beispiel 1 sehr leicht, 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen bedeutet.
Unerträglich, dann wäre ich schon längst hier gewesen, ja.
Ja, ich denke so um die Mitte rum, ja, so vielleicht ein bisschen mehr als die Mitte jetzt.
Also am Anfang vielleicht so bei 4, 4, 5 und jetzt vielleicht so bei 5, 6.
Also es ist nicht so, dass das unerträglich ist, aber es ist halt unangenehm und es lästig.
Und wenn es gar nicht weggeht, dann hat man halt auch so ein bisschen Sorgen, ja.
Okay, es tut mir sehr leid, dass Sie solche Schmerzen haben.
Strahlen Sie vielleicht irgendwo aus?
Nee, das ist eigentlich ziemlich auf dem unteren Bauch, da sind die Schmerzen.
Also nicht ins Bein oder in den Rücken oder so, da strahlt nichts, nee.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt nach dem fettigen Essen,
die Schmerzen sind schlimm. Okay, gibt es noch anderes Auslöser?
Naja, also ich habe jetzt natürlich mich ein bisschen geschont.
Ich habe jetzt also keinen Sport gemacht oder bin eben ja auch jetzt nicht wild rumgehüpft
oder irgendwie sowas, habe keine schwere Gartenarbeit gemacht, weil der Bauch eben weht hat, ja.
Okay, haben Sie schon ein Schmerzmittel genommen für diese Schmerzen?
Ja, also ich habe immer Paracetamol da und ja, dann habe ich das mal versucht,
aber ja, dann ist es mal ein klein bisschen besser, dann konnte ich meine Nacht gut schlafen,
aber so dass ich jetzt sagen könnte, das hat sich jetzt gebessert, kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay, ich verstehe. Und Frau Simamban, Entschuldigung, Herr Simamban,
ich hatte jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihrem allgemeinen Gesundheitszustand. Wie ist denn Ihr Appetit?
Ja, also zur Zeit ist es nicht so, normalerweise esse ich eigentlich gut und gerne, ja,
aber jetzt im Augenblick hat es mir so ein bisschen ja den Appetit verschlagen, ja.
Also ich esse nicht, im Augenblick schmeckt es mir nicht so gut.
Okay, essen Sie gerne Fleisch?
Ja, natürlich, ja.
Ja, okay, okay. Haben Sie in der letzter Zeit vielleicht ab oder zugenommen?
Also das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, ich wiege mich natürlich jetzt nicht jeden Tag,
aber also das hätte ich gemerkt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie stark ab oder zugenommen hätte.
Okay, okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, zur Zeit nicht so gut. Da wache ich manchmal nachts auf und dann zwickt der Bauch auch ein
bisschen und ja manchmal, wenn ich dann so Durchfallgeschichten habe, dann muss ich natürlich
auch auf die Toilette gehen, aber ja, da kann ich auch gut wieder einschlafen, so ist es nicht.
Okay, wie sagt dieser Durchfall aus?
Ja, wenn dann ist das eben, also ja genau wie sonst auch, aber eben weicher und flüssiger,
so ein bisschen, also nicht so geformt.
Okay, Sie haben nicht bemerkt Blut oder?
Blut habe ich nicht gesehen. Also so nicht verdauerte Essensreste, das sieht man dann
manchmal drin, dass da irgendwas nicht gekauft war oder so.
Okay, hatten Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrüche?
Nein, das nicht, aber manchmal muss ich so sauer aufstoßen, das ist ein bisschen
unangenehm. Und also insbesondere nach dem Essen fällt mir das auf, ja, also je nach
dem was es gab, also bei manchen Sachen ja, ups, dann kommt es so ein bisschen wieder hoch.
Okay, ich verstehe. Das ist schlecht für Sie, ich verstehe. Und gibt es Probleme beim
Ja, also ich habe so ein bisschen Probleme, dass ich manchmal auch nachts nochmal auf
die Toilette muss, aber noch nicht so oft.
Sie haben in der Nacht, Sie müssen Toilette gehen?
Manchmal muss ich nachts auf die Toilette gehen, also nicht jede Nacht, aber hin und
wieder ja.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe. Sie haben gesagt, Sauerstoff, Sauerstoff, aufstoßen, aufstoßen
gekommen. Und ist das die Langsam gestartet oder?
Noch mal, das habe ich nicht verstanden Ihre Frage.
Ist diese Beschwerden so lange gestartet oder in der letzten Zeit?
Schon lange, ja das habe ich eigentlich schon längere Zeit, ja.
Längere Zeit, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Nee, aber also schwitzen tue ich nicht in der Nacht, aber ja, tatsächlich habe
ich jetzt diese Tage manchmal so ein bisschen heiß gefühlt. Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber
ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass ich vielleicht ein bisschen Temperatur habe. Also ganz gut
fühle ich mich nicht zur Zeit.
Sind Sie vielleicht etwas müde als sonst?
Ja, eben auch dadurch, dass ich nicht so gut esse und dass ich nicht so gut
schlafe, bin ich ein bisschen schlapp, ja.
Okay, verstehe. Und Herr Zimmermann, haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen oder
vielleicht auch chronische Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck?
Ja, das ist mir egal. Ich bin 67 Jahre alt, ja, da haben das alle. Ich habe ein bisschen
hohen Blutdruck und ich habe natürlich auch so ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfettwerte.
Ja, also ich nehme da halt Tabletten. Und wenn ich, also ich habe da so einen
Better Blocker für den Blutdruck und ja, dann...
Eine Dosierung? Wissen Sie?
Oh, das kann ich eh nicht. Ich nehme da morgens und abends eine Tablette, aber
ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen, wie das heißt. Ja. Und wegen der Blutfettwerte
bekomme ich Athorvastatin. Da nehme ich abends eine Tablette.
Und können Sie diese Medikamente, die Dosierung?
Ja, da steht 20 drauf. Athorvastatin 20, da nehme ich abends eine Tablette.
Okay, okay. Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente? Regelmäßig?
Ja, also nicht ganz regelmäßig, aber manchmal wenn ich so das Gefühl habe,
ich kann nachts nicht gut einschlafen, dann nehme ich mal Baldrian-Tropfen.
Baldrian?
Ja, das ist nicht so oft.
Okay. Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, eigentlich kann ich alles vertragen. Also wir haben halt so eine Idee gehabt,
weil ich so Bauchschmerzen hatte, dass ich vielleicht Milch nicht vertragen kann.
Aber dann haben wir das mal weggelassen und dann war es aber auch nicht besser.
Also das scheint nicht der Hintergrund zu sein. Aber so eine richtige Allergie,
dass ich irgendwas, was weiß ich, dass ich den Pickle kriege oder Juckreiz oder so,
sowas habe ich nicht.
Okay. Rachen Sie Heisememann?
Nein, rauchen tue ich tatsächlich nicht. Das habe ich mir erspart, ja.
Das tut mir sehr leid. Freut?
Das freut Sie sehr, ja?
Ja, ja, ja. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also eigentlich trinke ich abends gerne ein Glas Wein, ja, ziemlich regelmäßig.
Wein?
Mhm.
Okay.
Im Winter gerne Rotwein, im Sommer dann, wenn es warm wird. Jetzt ist so die Zeit,
wo man dann anfängt, das reinzutrinken abends, ja.
Ja, ich verstehe, wenn die Sommer ist, ich wohne in Korp und es gibt viele gute Weine hier.
Ja, stimmt, natürlich, die Württemberger Weine, ja, genau.
Ja, ja, ja. Und wie geht es Ihren Eltern?
Naja, also die sind natürlich schon beide gestorben, ne? Die sind ja,
also ich bin ja schon fast 70, die leben beide nicht mehr. Und ja, mein Vater,
der war schon schwer krank, der hatte Lungenkrebs und hatte dann zusätzlich tatsächlich
noch einen Schlaganfall. Also der war dann zum Schluss ganz, ganz schlecht.
Und meine Mutter, ja, die hatte dann im hohen Alter so einen Alterszucker, ja.
Und die, also ja, aber eigentlich sind die beide alt geworden.
Ja, okay. Warum haben sie gestorben?
Also mein Vater hatte einen Schlaganfall und Lungenkrebs eben und meine Mutter
war dann letztendlich altersschwächer, keine Ahnung, aber die hatte jedenfalls
diesen Alterszucker da.
Okay, okay. Haben Sie auch Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister hatte ich nicht, ich war Einzelkind.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Okay. Und haben Sie auch Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind natürlich schon erwachsen, ne, die Kinder.
Und die leben auch nicht mehr bei uns, die sind jetzt schon lange aus dem Haus.
Okay. Ich hoffe, das ist eine gute Nacht für Sie, dass Sie leben.
Ja, irgendwann ist es gut, dann müssen die auf eigenen Füßen stehen, ja.
Okay, okay. Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei. Zwei.
Zwei Kinder.
Zwei. Okay. Ich hoffe, Sie sind auch gesund.
Die sind fit, so viel ich weiß, ja.
Okay, okay. Was machen Sie vom Beruflich?
Ja, ich bin seit Kurzem Rentner, aber noch nicht lange.
Und vorher habe ich in einem Möbelhaus gearbeitet als Verkäufer und Berater
und war da so Kundenbetreuer.
Verkäufer, Sie haben jetzt, oder? Okay.
Okay, dann, okay. Vielen Dank. Ich habe jetzt alle notwendige Informationen, denke ich.
Haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, natürlich. Also, was jetzt dahintersteckt, wie man das rausfinden kann
und was man dagegen machen kann gegen die Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Ob ich vielleicht operiert werden muss oder ob man Tabletten nehmen kann
oder was auch immer, ja.
Ja, natürlich. Ich verstehe, dass Sie wirklich große Sorgen machen.
Das ist verständlich. Aber wir sind hier für Sie und wir werden Ihnen helfen,
sich für eine sichere Diagnose zu erkennen.
Ich muss zuerst einige Untersuchungen machen.
Und danach, wenn wir alle vorliegen haben, werden wir die Diagnose bestiegen
und das zweite Vorgehen mit Ihnen besprechen.
Das klingt doch nach einem guten Plan, ja.
Okay. Ich bitte Sie draußen ein bisschen warten und ich werde auch noch Bescheid geben.
Ja, super. Das ist gut. Dann warte ich jetzt erst mal draußen.
Okay. Ich habe einen kleinen Moment. Ich brauche ein bisschen Moment.
Ja, jetzt fragen wir erstmal, ob von den Kollegen und Kolleginnen noch jemand etwas wissen möchte.
Wir haben jetzt zur Zeit, das fällt mir auf, seit einigen Wochen haben wir ja so eine ganz aktive Gruppe,
dass immer ganz viele Fragen kommen. Ich finde das total klasse, dass alle so engagiert sind und dabei sind.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob heute jetzt auch so viele Fragen kommen.
Wobei eigentlich, meine ich, Sie haben fast vollständig gefragt.
Ein paar Winzigkeiten haben Sie tatsächlich nicht gefragt. Mal gucken, ob was kommt.
Okay.
Darf ich Sie das fragen?
Ja.
Wurde Trauma oder eine Verletzung gefragt?
Wurde nicht gefragt. Ja, also irgendwie Bauchverletzung, Unfall oder sowas.
Ja, nee, das war aber nicht.
Aber das ist nicht so nötig in diesem Fall, oder?
Nee.
Okay. Dankeschön.
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Würde bei Ihnen irgendwelche Darm-Spiegelung durchgeführt?
Vor langer, langer Zeit mal, ja. Also im Rahmen dieser ersten Vorsorge untersuchen.
Aber das ist schon 15 Jahre her oder so, schon sehr lange her.
War das ganz normal?
Soviel ich weiß, ja. Da waren keine Besonderheiten, ja.
Dankeschön.
Na, genau, das war eine Frage, die noch gefehlt hat.
Impfstatus wurde nicht abgefragt.
Ja, aber wie alle braven Rentner ist auch Herr Zimmermann vollständig geimpft.
Guten Tag, Frau Chefärztin. Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit?
Ja, natürlich. Ihn haben Sie gesehen.
Okay, danke. Es handelt sich um einen 67-jährigen Patienten namens Frank Zimmermann,
der sich heute wegen linker Bauchschmerzen bei uns vorgestellt hat.
Die Beschwerden bestehen seit zwei Wochen und haben langsam begonnen.
Die Schmerzintestate wurde auf der Skala mit 5, 6, 10, 10 bewertet.
Die Beschwerden seien nach dem fertigen Essen aufgetreten und würden sich im Laufe der Zeit verstärken.
Begleitend berichtete er über Flatulenz, Pyrosis, vaserige Diarrheilung und Müdigkeit.
Gegen diese Beschwerden nehme er Paracetamol, was ihr auch einem schon helfen kann.
Was ein bisschen geholfen habe, ja.
Bis auf Insomnie, Inapetens und Inüctide ergaben sich keine Auffälligkeiten.
Die Fragen nach weiteren Beschwerden wurden verneint und es sei auch seit zwei Jahren dauernd.
Was ist seit zwei Jahren dauernd?
Die Beschwerden, Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, aber warum ist er denn nicht zum letzten Mal gekommen?
Nein, er hat gesagt, dass diese Bauchstörungen, hat sie seit zwei Jahren.
Die hat er schon seit zwei Jahren immer mal wieder, ne?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
An Vorerkrankungen sind arterielle Hypertonie und Hyperlipidemie bekannt.
Und für diese Vorerkrankungen nehme er Beta-Blocker, dosierung unbekannt, morgens und abends.
Und Atomestatin 20 mg am Abend.
Er hat keine Allergien und der Patient raucht nicht.
Und er trinkt ein Glas Wein am Abend.
Und Sozialanamnese, er ist Rentner und lebt mit seiner Frau.
Und früher arbeitete er als Immobilhausverkäufer.
Oh ja, okay.
Und in der Familienanamnese, der Vater verstarb an Lungenkrebs, Bronscherealkalzulone und Schlaganfall.
Ach Begriff? Apoplex.
Ja, ja.
Und die Mutter hat Diabetes-Mehligstück 2.
Hatte, lebt auch nicht mehr.
Ja, hätte, ja.
Und er ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Ja, das war alles. Und als Verdacht Diagnose halte ich eine chronische Pankreatitis für wahrscheinlich.
Okay, was könnte es Differential Diagnostisch sein?
Als Differential Diagnostik kommen Cholelytiasis und nicht sicher.
Denken Sie mal weiter an den Darm.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, kann sein. Sie sind, ja.
Das kann Divertikulitis sein, chronische Entzündung sein, zum Beispiel Mobiuskorn.
Genau.
Kankung kann sein auch als Differential Diagnosis.
Zur weiteren Abklärung würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Ja, worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Palpation. Zuerst mache ich Palpation, danach Oskultation und dann Laborkämie würde ich ein Blutbild sowie die Entzündungsparameter bestimmen.
Und noch auch CT veranlassen.
Therapeutisch plane ich.
Von welcher Diagnose gehen Sie aus?
Ich.
Wir müssen jetzt erst mal gucken, ob sich Ihre Diagnose von der Bauchspeicheldrüsenentzündung bestätigt.
Was spricht denn dafür?
Nach dem Essen hat diese Beschwerden verschlechter, würden verschlechter und Bauchschmerzen im linken Zeit habe sie.
Aber pro links.
Unteren.
Ja.
Ja, und die typischen Schmerzen von der Bauchspeicheldrüse, wie werden die denn beschrieben?
Da gibt es so einen Klassiker. Was sagen immer alle?
Jetzt denke ich, könnte ich nicht denken.
Entschuldigung.
Die sagen.
Die Vertikulitis kann sein.
Ja, gürtelförmig, genau, weil bei Pancreatitis sind die Schmerzen gürtelförmig.
Ja, und höher sitzend.
Und diese tief sitzenden Bauchschmerzen.
Es ist tatsächlich in diesem Fall kann ich ja verraten.
Es ist die Vertikulitis.
Ja, genau.
Jetzt müssen Sie natürlich noch Ihren Therapieplan darauf einrichten.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch dann mit den Patienten?
Für Diagnostische.
Und dann therapeutisch?
Ja, laborkämmig würde ich ein Blutbild bestimmen.
Das haben wir schon gesagt, ja?
Entschuldigung parametern.
Und zu hoch als Differenzialdiagnose.
Ich muss Amylase, Lipase und LDH wie so weiter bestimmen.
Und nach diesem Beschwerden muss ich auch Koloskopie veranlassen.
Ja, genau. Vielleicht es einen tut.
Ja, muss er leider durch, der Patient.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und im körperlichen Untersuchung auch.
Ich muss digitale, rechte Untersuchung.
Sehr gut. Okay.
Ja, okay. Gut.
Und was machen Sie denn dann therapeutisch, wenn Sie wissen,
der hat tatsächlich eine Vertikulitis?
Ich habe jetzt alle vergessen.
Ja, wie ist das denn? Darf der Mutter weiter essen?
Nein, darf er weiter essen?
Er muss weniger Fett essen. Nahrungsgrenze.
Er soll gar nichts. Er soll erst mal parenteral ernährt werden.
Der braucht einen Zugang.
Ja.
Der braucht einen Zugang und wird parenteral ernährt.
Und ich muss auch Analgetika geben und auch, wenn nötig,
Antibiotika.
Ja, genau.
Muss ich auch verschreiben.
Und dann kann man hoffen, dass es funktioniert.
Und wenn nicht, muss man operieren.
Ja.
Okay. Gut.
Ja, schön. Danke.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was mit den Patienten ist,
wie Ihre Befunde sind und wie wir weiter vorgehen sollen.
Ja, gut.
Wir kommen gleich zur Manöverkritik.
Also, ich fand, Sie haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Und auch sprachlich völlig unproblematisch.
Was mir dann aufgefallen ist, als Sie mit einem mal frei formulieren sollten,
als der Patient gesagt hat, ja, wie geht es denn jetzt weiter, was kann denn sein.
Da mussten Sie von Ihrem Konzept runter.
Da mussten Sie was Neues antworten und waren da nicht so gut vorbereitet.
Und da hatten Sie ein bisschen Formulierungsschwierigkeiten.
Also für den Fall, dass der Patient tatsächlich Ihnen eine Frage stellt,
sollten Sie gewappnet sein und sollten sich vielleicht ein paar Formulierungen
vornotieren, schon überlegen, was könnte ich denn sagen.
Ja, das hängt natürlich immer ab vom Fall, was der Patient jetzt gerade für Beschwerden hat.
Ja, was ich ganz schön fand, dass Sie zwischendurch immer gesagt haben,
ja, ich kann Ihre Sorge verstehen, aber Sie sind bei uns in guten Händen,
machen Sie sich jetzt mal keine Sorgen.
Entspannen Sie sich mal, wir müssen, wir gucken ja nach Ihnen.
Gut, dass Sie gekommen sind.
Ja, ein bisschen gut zugeredet.
Aber dann eben hinterher, als er dann so zum Schluss gefragt hat,
ja, wie geht es Ihnen jetzt weiter?
Da sollten Sie schon eigentlich ja so eine vorformulierte Geschichte haben,
dass Sie sagen, ja, bisher habe ich ja nur mit Ihnen gesprochen.
Jetzt sind natürlich noch einige Untersuchungen notwendig.
Ich habe zwar eine Idee, was dahinterstecken könnte, aber lassen Sie uns erst gucken.
Ich muss Ihnen natürlich auch noch Blut abnehmen.
Und jetzt in diesem Fall, ja, vielleicht müssen wir auch noch Stuhl- und Urin untersuchen,
ob da irgendwas ist, was Ihnen Beschwerden macht.
Ja, also, dass man halt je nachdem, wie die Beschwerden sind, sagt, ja, wir gucken weiter.
Ja, und wenn wir alle Untersuchungen zusammen haben und alle Ergebnisse,
dann kann ich Ihnen vermutlich sagen, was Sie haben.
Und dann können wir auch sagen, wie wir weiter vorgehen.
Okay, verstehe, ja.
Aber lassen Sie sich dazu einfach vielleicht noch mal ein paar Notizen machen,
ein paar schöne Sätze, dass Sie sie abrufen können.
Ja, ich vorbereite diese Sätze an.
Ich bereite das vor.
Ja.
Vorbereiten ist ein Tränenbauswerb.
Ja, gut.
Einmal haben Sie sich wunderbar selber korrigiert.
Da musst du so lachen.
Und dann mache ich, ja, da haben Sie es gemerkt, das ist meine sensible Stelle.
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist gleich im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
Gewicht und Größe haben Sie gar nicht erst gesagt.
Weiß ich nicht, ob Sie das bei Ihnen in Baden-Württemberg wissen wollen oder nicht.
Könnte sein.
Es gibt ja auch diese klassischen Formulierungen in gutem Ernährungszustand
oder in reduziertem oder in adipösen Ernährungszustand.
In diesem Fall hier würde man ja sagen, in gutem oder normalem Ernährungszustand.
Mit 80 Kilo ist er ja, oder 79 Kilo ist er ja nicht so schwer für seine 1,73.
Für einen Mann, für eine Frau wäre es ein bisschen viel.
Ja, gut.
Dann haben wir, ja, und dann haben Sie gleich gesagt,
eigentlich hat ein schöner Satz, stellte sich vor wegen, er hat linke Bauchschmerzen.
Nee, er hat linkseitige Unterbauchschmerzen oder Abdominalbeschwerden.
Mit den Fachbegriffen, die müssen ein bisschen, müssen Sie ein bisschen mehr einschließen.
Es wirkt im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch natürlich wissenschaftlicher und kollegialer,
wenn Sie die Fachbegriffe nehmen.
Im Patientengespräch ist natürlich richtig, dass Sie die normalen Wörter,
die deutschen Wörter nehmen, praktisch, die der Patient auch versteht,
je nachdem, was Sie nun für einen Patienten vor sich haben.
Aber linke Bauchschmerzen sollten Sie im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch wirklich nicht sagen,
sondern wenn schon linkseitige Abdominalbeschwerden.
Ja, gut.
Dann waren Sie so ein bisschen unsicher.
Der hat ja gesagt, seit zwei Wochen hat er das.
Und dann haben Sie mit einem Mal gesagt, der hat es schon seit zwei Jahren.
Also seit zwei Jahren hat er schon Verdauungsbeschwerden.
Dass er immer mal Bauchschmerzen, immer mal Durchfall und mal Verstopfung hat.
Aber jetzt hat er eben zusätzlich diese Bauchschmerzen.
Und das ist relativ aktuell. Und die sind halt nach Fettigem Essen.
Schmerzen haben Sie richtig angegeben, Vorerkrankungen auch.
Ja, dann im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch auch.
Da haben Sie so ein bisschen wie abgelesen vom Zettel.
Sozialanamnese. Der Patient ist verheiratet, hat zwei Kinder.
Da sollte man vielleicht sagen, zur Sozialanamnese gab der Patient an.
Also einen kleinen Verbindungs-Satz da herstellen.
Ebenso familienanamnistisch ergab sich.
Oder auf die Frage nach familiären Erkrankungen gab der Patient an.
Nicht nur als Überschrift.
Familienanamnese, Vater hat das und das, Mutter hat das und das.
Altersbedingte sind natürlich beide tot.
Wenn jemand 67 Jahre ist, dann hat er im Normalfall, naja gut, gibt schon, dass die Eltern dann noch leben.
Aber nicht zwingend. In diesem Fall sind halt beide verstorben.
Aber das war auch das einzige, würde ich sagen.
Sonst habe ich mir gar nichts weiter aufgeschrieben.
Was bei den Kollegen jetzt noch nachgefragt wurde, die beiden Punkte, wo ich gesagt habe,
da hat er gar nicht nachgefragt, nach dem Impfstatus haben sie nicht gefragt.
Und nach der Reiseanamnese haben sie auch nicht gefragt.
Da der Typ jetzt nicht mit einer akuten Durchfallerkrankung oder mit hohem Fieber kommt,
denke ich auch immer, dass der eine Tropenkrankheit hat, ist nicht so wahrscheinlich.
In der Prüfung sollten sie der Vollständigkeit halber die beiden Dinge mit abfragen.
Ich nutze diese Frage.
Ich meine, es wird allgemein gefordert, dass das abgefragt wird.
Und dann waren sie halt mit ihrer Diagnose, mit der Bauchspeicheldrüse,
waren sie ein bisschen auf dem falschen Dampfer.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die sich immer an ihre klassischen Fälle halten,
aber eben diese typische Beschwerden, die sich immer an ihre klassischen Fälle halten,
aber eben diese typische Beschreibung der Schmerzen bei Pankreatitis
als wirklich schörmig und die sitzen einfach höher.
Die Bauchspeicheldrüse sitzt ja so praktisch unter dem Rippenbogen,
wenn ich mir das vorstelle.
Und die Schmerzen gibt er ja deutlich tiefer an.
Der gibt die ja irgendwie im Aszendenz, Dezendenz in irgendeinem Kohlernbereich an.
Und insofern denke ich mal, dass die Divertikulitis da schon so ein bisschen auf dem Zettel war
und dass die relativ nahe lag.
Und die kamen ja auch sofort hier von ihren Kollegen.
Aber darum geht es ja in der Prüfung gar nicht.
In der Prüfung geht es nicht, dass sie die richtige Diagnose stellen,
sondern da geht es darum, dass sie sich sprachlich gut raushelfen.
Ich denke mal, da haben sie sich gut geschlagen.
Sie können glaube ich wirklich ohne große Sorgen da ihre Prüfung antreten.
Und das wird sicher...
Erstaunlich, haben Sie in der Türkei schon Deutsch gelernt?
Ja, ein bisschen habe ich gestartet, aber hier...
Krass, also in 20 Monaten so gut Deutsch sprechen, das finde ich schon...
Du kriegst gut, ja super.
Danke.
Okay, ja dann.
Für heute Abend haben wir es geschafft.